hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we will be reviewing
weight loss youtuber
beatrice caruso but first let me take
you briefly out of my kitchen so i can
tell you about my sponsor oats overnight
if you've watched my morning routine you
know that mornings over here are
well a lot things can get a little bit
hectic
and i need some solid but fast fuel to
keep me going
so oats have always been a go-to
grab-and-go option
and now it's even easier with oats
overnight
this is legit the fastest breakfast
of life you just add your favorite milk
or non-dairy milk to the shaker
add a pack of oats overnight give it a
shake
throw it in the fridge and the next
morning you just give it one last shake
and it's ready to eat you don't even
need a spoon which
i mean takes convenience to a whole new
level what i love most about them is
that they are perfectly balanced for a
post-workout snack or a simple breakfast
so each serving contains about 20 grams
of whey
or pea based protein plus complex carbs
fiber iron and more they're low in sugar
gluten-free
and loaded with nutritious add-ins like
hemp hearts and chia seeds
they have a bunch of really awesome
flavors but i am low-key
obsessed with the peanut butter cookie
crunch and the peach upside down cake
so if you want to give oats overnight a
try check out my promo link
in the description below so you can
pause the screen or of course look at
the description to check out my
disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating
i will be talking macros and calories
so feel free to skip that portion if it
isn't supportive to
your journey and of course don't forget
to subscribe to this channel
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out on a video
all right folks a little background on
beatrice beatrice
started her channel after gaining weight
like so many of us did during quarantine
and she decided to document her weight
loss journey and progress
here on youtube now when her first video
was filmed
she weighed 252 pounds which she said
was the heaviest that she'd ever been
she also suggested that she had tried to
lose weight in the past
and never had had long-term success so
her goal this time around was to find a
sustainable weight loss plan
and provide an honest and authentic look
at the weight loss experience
you guys know i'm all for honesty and
authenticity so
today we're going to be looking at her
most recent what i in a day at the time
of filming this video
where she was down 30 pounds since her
starting weight
hey guys so i just want to do a quick
little pick up here about a week ago
beatrice came out suggesting that she's
been suffering from
binge eating and that it has been
stalling her weight loss
and will likely continue to stall her
weight loss
now i actually thought about pulling
this whole video
and not posting it at all because i
really don't want to
promote a weight loss diet for anyone
that has
disordered eating or an active eating
disorder
i don't want this to be triggering for
anyone including
for beatrice but ultimately beatrice
actually said
in this video that she's going to
continue to
try to lose weight but that the focus
for her is going to be on healing from
her binging which i really strongly
believe
is the right focus for her for most
people it is
way too triggering to try to actively be
losing weight
while suffering from an active eating
disorder because
often the restriction is what triggers
the binge so beatrice if you are
watching right now
please feel free to not watch
if it's going to be triggering to see
any commentary on your weight loss
journey
so if and when beatrice is able to get
to a better place with regards to her
relationship with food
with the help of her health care team
some of the gentle nutrition tips that i
share
later on in this video for her such as
actually eating
more may actually help to prevent
relapse in the future
and that may be within or outside the
context
of actively trying to lose weight i also
decided to keep this video up to really
prove
that you know even so-called healthy
weight loss journeys
can sometimes be disordered there's
really no
way to know what's going on in someone's
mind
just from watching a few youtube videos
so if my read on the situation was off
and i humbly admit it was completely off
then you can imagine that a lot of
people who are
watching this at home are gonna miss
that nuance
this ultimately goes to show that what
we see
on youtube is often just a sliver
of what's going on in real life
and i don't think that beatrice was
trying to be dishonest
or deceive her audience i actually
really commend
and respect her bravery on coming out
with this information
but it's a good reminder that what can
often
look healthy to an outsider can often be
really far from it so use this video
more as like a string of teachable
moments and tips
rather than individualized information
or recommendations for
beatrice herself because ultimately a
lot of it may or may not
apply right now actually that's really
the purpose of my content in
general it's not so much about the
individual youtuber
as it is an opportunity for me to teach
nutrition facts in a bit more of an
entertaining
and real-life way but anyways i will be
following beatrice's journey and maybe
if you guys are interested i can do a
follow-up video
if and when we have a few more facts and
a bit more information
to unpack the whole binge eating piece
in its entirety
a little bit more anyways thank you guys
for your patience now let's get back to
my original assessment
of beatrice's weight loss journey and
diet
also please do not unsubscribe from
beatrice just because her weight loss
is not going to be as dramatic as maybe
it was before
her recovery uh beatrice i want you to
know
that i support you and i am here for you
so you got this girl press the button on
the keurig
okay so here's breakfast this is our cup
of oats and then i'm just having a half
cup of blueberries on the side
because blueberries are delicious
okay so this seems like a really
delicious and well-balanced breakfast to
me
we've got some complex carbs and fiber
from the oats and berries
protein from the protein powder that she
popped in and let's be real
the obligatory caffeine hit from the
coffee now this
might be enough to sustain her for a few
hours but i would say that a lot of us
would need
probably more calories and some healthy
fats to help carry us through
this is a pretty low calorie breakfast
so
to achieve that hunger crushing
combination that we all
know and love she could kind of swirl in
some
maybe nut butter or top her bowl off
with some hemp hearts
chia or flax to give it a little bit
more texture
let's see what's next are we a chef
i'm very surprised that it came out
looking like the picture because
if you all know my track record with
following recipes is not good
i'm stoked about the honey dijon
dressing
i'm gonna have kale in my teeth for the
rest of this video but very good okay so
after a walk with her mom beatrice preps
lunch which
is sponsored by a meal kit service and
honestly
it looks pretty awesome she did a really
great job
super restaurant quality looking but
also
pretty easy as well a lot of people
actually ask me about my thoughts on
meal kit services
and generally speaking i think they're
pretty great
i am all for prioritizing family meals
so
if taking some shortcuts in the kitchen
helps you get a relaxing
meal on the table i am here for it no
not all kits are perfectly balanced and
some could probably have a few more
vegetables in there or whatever but
at the end of the day especially for
most folks who are just
you know getting started trying to eat
healthier i'm really not about
perfection
i am about realistic mealtime solutions
and for a lot of busy folks this is a
really great option
i also think that it helps a lot of
people get out of cooking ruts
so even if you're leaning on these kits
for short stints
just get some more cooking inspiration i
think that there's value in that too
anyway i think that beatrice's choice is
one of the more nutritious options that
i've seen
so she's got some really good quality
protein and fat from the chicken
and the vinaigrette plus tons of fiber
rich
veg from the kale salad and mushrooms i
would say that the meal
is lower in carbs which beatrice
actually points out herself
saying that she loves her carb but is
trying to limit her carb intake to help
her lose weight
and while this may be working for her as
low carb does
actually work for a lot of dieters i
just want to flag that
you don't necessarily need to cut out
carbs to lose weight
as i talked about in my video reviewing
youtubers weight loss advice right here
at its core weight loss is largely about
eating
in a steady caloric deficit a lot of
people do see more immediate shifts on
the scale starting a low carb diet but
this is largely due to
water loss as the body's glycogen stores
start to deplete
not actually from losing a ton of fat
right out the gates
longer term we do have a large
meta-analysis from this past
december that showed that low carb had a
slight weight loss advantage over low
fat but the difference was actually less
than
three pounds and the low fat folks had
better control
on their cholesterol levels i don't
think that we can make broad assumptions
that one approach is universally better
for weight loss than the other
it likely comes down to individual
differences in metabolism
and also just what feels more
sustainable and easy
to people based on their food
preferences
protein and fat are more satiating than
carbohydrates so
often people feel more full on a lower
carb diet but at the end of the day
it really comes down to maintaining a
caloric deficit
whether that comes at the expense of
dietary carbs
protein or fat now from what i could see
from her other videos and also her other
meals
beatrice doesn't seem to be anti-carb by
any means like
she regularly enjoys foods like cereal
rice
bread without any guilt or like beating
herself
up for it and in the context of this day
she
really might have just been craving a
lower carb lunch
after her oatmeal and berry breakfast so
again if it works for her it works for
me
i just kind of wanted to debunk the carb
hating misinformation out there
cause your girl loves carbs time to
carboload
and on that note let's see what's for
dinner so i did that thing that i
unfortunately do from time to time where
i think i'm recording but in fact
i am not regardless for dinner i had
barbecue pork
green beans and ready rice okay so this
looks like a pretty
balanced plate of protein fat carbs and
veg
it isn't fancy it isn't particularly
super instagramable
but if you're looking for a simple
example of what a balanced plate can
look like
it doesn't get more textbook than this
and i appreciate also that
she's switching it up and including a
non-stereotypical diet protein like
pulled pork
in the mix here that's actually going to
offer a little bit more fat
for some more staying power and probably
also more satisfaction factor as well
because let's be real a girl can only
eat
so much extra lean turkey and chicken
breasts before she totally taps out so
yeah
this looks totally yum to me but let's
take a look at her bedtime snack
and i don't know why but a bowl of
cereal at night time just hits different
it's sweet it's carby it's delicious why
do i crave
the things that are bad for me well not
bad for you
okay so special k with coconut milk and
berries seems like a fine bedtime snack
if you're craving something crunchy
and sweet i am low-key obsessed with
cereal
at all hours of the day so i totally
feel her
on that but there are a few things that
i want to unpack
about beatrice's suggestion that eating
cereal helps her control her sugar
cravings
first as your resident youtube dietitian
i just want to let everyone know
that sugar is not the devil that we are
all taught
that it is is it the most nutrient rich
mineral packed food that you can eat on
the planet
absolutely not but is a little bit of
sugar eaten in moderation bad for you
also absolutely not now while sugar
isn't something
we really need to consume in excess a
sweet snack or two
is not going to make or break your
health bank
especially if you're consuming a
generally varied and balanced diet
in fact it's often this sugar is always
bad for you mentality
that contributes to overwhelming sugar
cravings and overeating in the first
place
classic diet mentality we will always
fantasize about the things we say we
shouldn't
have so i know that beatrice is in a
weight loss phase so
by nature she's going to potentially be
a little restricted
and depending on her level of caloric
restriction
there may be some of that scarcity
mentality going on
but for most people watching especially
those who are not
in an active weight loss phase i really
urge you to try to neutralize our
morality around food when we stop
thinking about food in dichotomous terms
like good versus bad food
we're much less likely to obsess over
and crave the demonized foods
and much more likely to find pleasure in
naturally nourishing foods
so if beatrice is having a sugar craving
before bed it might be a sign that her
body actually needs more carbs
so this could mean allowing herself a
little more carbs
at her snacks and lunch even if it means
a more gradual and steady weight loss
pace
second let's talk about health halos
[Music]
so a health halo is the perception that
a particular food is
good for you even when there is little
or no evidence to confirm that this is
true
special k has a health halo as it's long
been marketed
as a diet friendly option probably
because it's relatively low in calories
and fat free but if we compare the
labels of
special k red berries to let's say a
stereotypical
sugar packed cereal like cinnamon toast
crunch
you can see that they're really not that
different
there's nothing wrong with either of
these cereals so choose whichever one
that you actually
like and it is very possible that
beatrice just loves
special k i like it too but if you're
choosing the diet cereal thinking that
it's
a healthier choice which then just
stimulates the scarcity mentality that
results in a binge it's probably better
to just
have a bowl of cinnamon toast crunch and
call it a day
and on that note let's break down the
stats and
trigger warning i am about to talk
numbers so
feel free to skip ahead to the time
stamp on the screen
if that may be triggering to you so
according to
beatrice's own calorie counting her
nutrition for the day came out to be
about
1543 calories with 31
coming from protein and fat and 38
coming from
carbs she is a little bit low in vitamin
e
d calcium and omega-3 fats but otherwise
she's meeting most of her other
micronutrient needs
i did notice that she takes some of
these as supplements in
another video so i'm happy to hear that
she's got that going on as well
but let's switch gears and discuss what
i really like here
one part of beatrice's videos that
really makes me happy
is her disclaimers where she's talking
about something that maybe is out of her
field of expertise
for example in one of her videos
beatrice is diving into her supplement
routine where she's discussing how
taking fish oil and vitamin d has really
helped to
improve her mood and mental health while
i'm of course glad that those
supplements are
working for her what i love most here is
that she puts a disclaimer at the end of
that segment stating that
she can't definitively attribute being
or feeling better to those supplements
and that she's not a medical
professional period
but she has found that taking these
supplements are helpful
for her because there's so much
misinformation
on the internet in combination with also
a range of people claiming to be experts
in fields that they are not certified in
i always love when someone acknowledges
that the advice that they're giving is
out of their scope
so hats off to you beatrice love that
but as an aside
in case you're wondering she did appear
to get some good advice on the
supplements
as both vitamin d and fish oil have been
shown to play a role in improving
and regulating mood so love that now in
terms of beatrice's approach to weight
loss
i really appreciate that there isn't any
misinformation
about food or demonizing of certain food
groups
in fact beatrice eats all sorts of carbs
and fats and protein
from a variety of sources she also is
not afraid to eat typically
demonized carbs like white bread
especially for somebody who
is trying to lose weight she's really
just trying to eat a variety of
satiating and satisfying foods
that she actually likes while
maintaining a caloric deficit that feels
doable for her
and that to me is probably the best case
scenario
for any kind of weight loss diet it's
not easy to do as it does take
a lot more thinking and planning and
ultimately
some nutrition knowledge but i think in
the end she will be
better equipped to maintain a routine
like this
long term beatrice also discusses her
goals for the future in a different
video
titled six month body transformation
update now in this video she talks about
how she lost
almost 40 pounds so far she goes on to
say that she has a variety of goals to
work towards while she continues her
weight loss efforts
such as beginning strength training
increasing her protein intake and
decreasing her carbs
drinking more water sticking to a 1555
calorie
diet per day and continuing to
prioritize
her mental health so let's break down
some of these goals
first of all i totally support her
inclination to begin
weight training for those of you who may
not know the more
muscle you have the more fat you
potentially can burn
because muscle is metabolically active
and can increase our body's resting
metabolic rate
one study found that 16 weeks of
resistance training
increased participants rmr or resting
metabolic rate
by 6.8 percent and another meta-analysis
found
significantly greater improvements in
rmr for subjects performing resistance
training
compared to aerobic exercise so
definitely a great call on the decision
to lift weights
even if you are not trying to lose
weight second in terms of beatrice's
protein to carb ratio
the research is very clear that in the
macronutrient satiety hierarchy
protein is king because it keeps you
fuller
longer after a meal for a smaller amount
of calories per gram
protein is also thought to help support
a healthy metabolism because
it has a greater thermic effect of food
aka tee
than other macronutrients and therefore
requires
more energy to break down and digest so
for example
protein requires about 20 to 30 percent
of your energy output to digest
while carbs use about five to ten
percent and fats
generally use between zero to three
percent it also is essential for
building
muscle mass and as we already discussed
muscle
is more metabolically active than fat
that being said
carbs are also helpful in the muscle
building equation since
carbs help stimulate an insulin response
to drive the protein into the muscle
faster
so we don't want to demonize carbs but
we also don't want to
overload on protein either too much
protein can also
lead to fat gain and also elicit its own
insulin response so that's ultimately
why
balance is key here next regarding
beatrice's goal to drink more water
what i can say of course is hydration is
never a bad thing in my books
as we all know water is vital to
literally every single process
our body carries out for us and while
you probably don't need me to tell you
this
water will not necessarily boost your
metabolism
or automatically lead to miraculous
weight loss
it is however just a good idea to stay
hydrated in general especially if
beatrice is planning on
upping her exercise routine beatrice
also discusses her goal of sticking to
1555 calories in order to lose weight
very specific
i will speak more to this in a moment
but i don't really think that this would
be considered an
ideal caloric deficit for someone in
beatrice's baseline weight age and
activity level
if anything she actually might find more
success
in upping her calories a bit especially
if she's going to be
beginning with a lot of weight training
at the end of the day
it's very hard to build muscle if you're
not eating enough to repair those fibers
beatrice also runs the risk of
unintentionally slowing her metabolism
down a little bit
if she's maintaining too much of a
caloric deficit for too
long now i get the general vibe from
beatrice that it isn't her intention to
starve herself by any means
this is actually just a really common
move when people attempt to lose weight
without a lot of professional support
it's just my suggestion that she may not
only achieve her results
but she may also feel better by
re-examining her
designated amount of calories i'm not
sure where she got that number from
but just keep in mind that a lot of
online calorie counters
are very inaccurate they cannot
tell you exactly how many calories your
body
optimally needs not for maintenance and
not for weight loss
a lot of this is trial and error and
that's where having
an expert like a registered dietitian
really would come into play
lastly i always commend anyone for not
only prioritizing their mental health
but also having the courage to speak up
about their struggles
on a public platform i have also
struggled with anxiety all of my life
but i
think talking about it and normalizing
it
helps to reduce stigma and ultimately
get more people help
so i'm definitely proud of beatrice for
not only being open about her mental
health
but also stating out loud that she's
really trying to make it a priority for
herself
now let's talk about some gentle
nutrition tips
now i'm not sure what beatrice was
eating before she started this diet
but just basing my assumptions on her
starting weight
and my crude estimations of her baseline
caloric needs
i would say that beatrice's caloric
deficit may actually be
a little too aggressive for sustainable
weight loss
i know it's easy to fall into the trap
that more calorie cutting is better
but this often results in metabolic
adaptation which
makes it harder to lose weight and also
can result in complete burnout from
taking on too much
too fast beatrice herself was saying in
this video
that she was feeling pretty burnt out
when it came to her weight loss efforts
and her caloric deficit may actually
explain
why that might be i also don't really
think that
diet challenges that she does like going
keto for a week or whatever and doing
the one meal a day thing are gonna help
to invigorate her or motivate her
if anything i would think that these
extreme ways of eating
can take a huge emotional and mental
toll on a person
it's like trying to learn and relearn
your body's needs
every single week i would encourage
beatrice to find
little ways to tweak or add things to
her diet
that she actually enjoys and to stick to
those
in the long run lastly let's talk about
beatrice's relationship with food
so beatrice states that while her
ultimate goal is to get to a place of
intuitive eating
that it's just not something that she
feels she can do right now
as she thinks she will totally lose
control around food
and eat like an entire cake there's
actually a few things that i want to
point out here
first of all intuitive eating isn't
necessarily for
everyone in its entirety meaning that
not all of the
principles are going to apply to every
person
at every stage of life for every goal
intuitive eating is
also not a weight loss diet so if you've
been dieting for a very long time
and you suddenly decide to listen to
your body right out the gates
you will probably overeat a lot of the
previously restricted
and demonized foods this is actually to
be entirely expected
it's part of the process however
generally speaking
this phase does not last forever will
you
naturally restrict enough to be able to
lose weight as she currently
is likely not especially if that lower
weight
is not where her set point is but again
that is not the point or benefit of
intuitive eating
the benefit is that you typically no
longer
are yo-yoing between restriction and
binging
and that you can free yourself of the
exhausting task
of constantly thinking about food as
i've actually discussed in an entire
video
on my channel which i'll link right here
i am absolutely not against intentional
weight loss
i just want to flag that intuitive
eating shouldn't be labeled as
an eat whatever you want whenever you
want diet
as it's a lot more nuanced and complex
than that
i actually have an entire playlist
dedicated to explaining
and discussing intuitive eating on my
channel if any of you are more curious
or have more specific questions
definitely check that out
all in all not only was beatrice a
pleasure to watch for
a variety of food related reasons as we
discussed
she's also honestly just really sweet
and funny
and relatable and i really appreciate
that
in the sea of youtube wellness
influencers so
i definitely can recommend checking out
her channel if you haven't already
well folks we covered a lot of ground
and that is all that i have for today
if you like this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on who you'd like to see me review
next
subscribe to the channel i'll see you
next time on abby's kitchen
bye